let's go uh first uh to Martha Kellner
who is in Palm Beach so Martha well tell
us what's the uh what's the scene there
this is uh quite some 48 hours ahead
it certainly is a historic 48 hours for
this country Donald Trump's still
somewhere behind those Gates leading to
his private Mar-A-Lago estate in one of
the cluster of buildings just making his
final preparations preparations for a
journey that no former or sitting
president has ever done a journey
towards being formally charged with
crimes federal crimes in this case and
no one really could create a spectacle
like this around their own surrender
quite like Donald Trump has done his
team uh briefing journalists on what to
expect when he leaves Mar-A-Lago we're
expecting that to be any minute now and
he will be escorted in a motorcade
together with his secret service detail
that are always
um with him that luxury authored to all
former presidents he'll be brought
across the bridge behind me Bingham
Island Bridge which links his Mar-A-Lago
home with Palm Beach and he'll head
towards Palm Beach International support
that you mentioned it's less than a 10
minute drive from his front door and to
the tarmac at Palm Beach International
Airport and they're waiting for him will
be Trump Force One the nickname for his
own private plane which will then take
him on a journey lasting just a little
over two hours into New York where he'll
face these criminal charges tomorrow
he'll stay overnight as you mentioned in
Trump Tower and it's at that point
tomorrow afternoon when he appears in
front of the judge in the Bowery
District of Manhattan the public will
finally learn what these charges are
because at the moment this is a sealed
indictment a sealed charge sheet if you
like so we don't know exactly what
Donald Trump is to be charged with but
we do know it relates to push money
payments made to the porn star Stormy
Daniels in the dying days of the 2016
campaign election payments uh totaling
around 130 000 payments made by Trump's
former lawyer and fixer Michael Cohen
it's not specifically the payments that
are illegal those those aren't illegal
it's the manner those payments were made
and the Declaration of them
and uh we're just seeing uh at least one
car leaving uh Mar-A-Lago
um whether that would be um Donald Trump
is doubtful given that he would be with
his uh security detail so uh
um Martha you were saying I mean we
don't know the exact detail of the
charges but we do know that Donald Trump
is defiant and uh will fight this case
yeah and we know that these are serious
charges these are federal crimes not
misdemeanors
um that they're suspected uh that he's
suspected of having committed and legal
experts while obviously not being drawn
on the specifics of what this indictment
will contain they say it could have a
maximum prison sentence of four years so
we're really facing up to the
possibility that Donald Trump who has
already declared that he's going to run
for the presidency once again in 2024
concurrently we could have a criminal
trial uh with his um campaign election
of course he has to get through the
Republican primaries before we get to
that point but as you were mentioning
Donald Trump remaining defiant he says
he hasn't broken the law and in either
this case or any of the other potential
criminal investigations
um that he's facing and in fact he's
been using this indictment as you might
expect to Galvanize his most loyal
supporters he's called it a a Witch Hunt
he's urged his supporters to protest
this in this indictment and warned of
death and destruction and in fact and
just before this indictment was made
public he made his first appearance of
this 2024 campaign a rally in Waco Texas
um in which he played a video of the
January the 6th and storming of the
capital almost seemed to be celebrating
that Insurrection he's also called the
district attorney Alvin Bragg the man
responsible and for bringing these
charges against him he's called him a
degenerate degenerate psychopath so you
can really see that Trump is trying to
flip these bad headlines and to try and
work in his favor he's trying to
Galvanize his supporters to believe that
this is simply a Witch Hunt to try and
wipe him off the political map
yeah and as you say uh Martha it could
be argued that this is or could well be
the least serious case that or
investigation that faces Trump at the
moment with those other investigations
that are going on into the January the
6th
um riots the The Taking of those top
secret documents out of uh the white
house uh to that place that we're seeing
now on the pictures to Mar-A-Lago and
there's also the interfering uh with the
2020 election in Georgia so you know
several other investigations going on
that could pose a more serious challenge
to Donald Trump's uh
you know standing for the next
presidency
yeah this is by some distance not the
most serious potential charge that
Donald Trump faces you mentioned there
and some of the more outstanding I guess
some of some of the more exceptional
cases of the many uh legal difficulties
that he faces at the moment you
mentioned that investigation into
um into potential interference in the
2020 election particularly at the
counting of votes in the state of
Georgia an investigation ongoing into
whether Donald Trump committed crimes in
that counting of those election votes in
Georgia also not so long ago a few
months ago the FBI raided his Mar-A-Lago
residence removing top secret documents
um from his home here so many oh I think
we might have the motorcade just leaving
Mar-A-Lago coming through the gates now
yeah that's right we're seeing pictures
of
of the former president uh Donald Trump
if he was
still president it would be uh
a much bigger motorcade than that but
he's off on his way to uh the local
airport where he will pick up his flight
to uh LaGuardia
in New York City and then he will
be off the Trump Tower for the night
before the uh arraignment hearing
tomorrow
at Martha it's interesting isn't it the
reaction of
people in Florida the governor of
Florida Donald Trump's main Republican
rival in many ways Ron DeSantis
supporting Trump in this saying I think
he said it was Un-American and that his
that his State could not support it
Martha
yeah we're just waiting now for the
motorcade to come past a good handful of
Donald Trump's supporters here trying to
catch a glimpse of him I didn't see him
wind down his window there
um but he's certainly trying to make a
moment of this occasion he's now zooming
towards Palm Beach International Airport
on this long road this Southern
with Palm Beach and he'll be at the
airport in a matter of minutes now less
than 10 minutes but yes as you mentioned
the the political complexion here in
Florida is interesting at the moment
Donald Trump the first Republican to
declare that he will run for the
presidency in 2024 but it may very well
be that he faces stifle position in his
own state from Ron DeSantis who's the
current governor of Florida incredibly
popular here a much younger man than
Donald Trump and Donald Trump in many
ways uh gave his career his political
career of Rhonda santis a serious boost
Donald Trump considers himself
responsible for Rhonda Sanchez's rise to
prominence but it may be that when these
Republican primaries
um come around next year that it is a
Face-Off between Ron DeSantis and Donald
Trump many people here are calling it
Ron versus Don some people uh joking
that this will be and battle for the
White House in Florida so Donald Trump
is not going to to have a clear run for
the Republican candidacy but he is
certainly most people's favorite at the
moment and certainly he hopes that this
indictment will work to his advantage
okay Martha thank you very much for the
moment as we watch uh Donald Trump's
motorcade head to the local airport
let's go to where he's going which is
New York and Trump Tower in New York and
James Matthews is there and James he'll
be spending the night there we're told
and no doubt preparing for what is
happening tomorrow when he heads off to
the Lower Manhattan offices of the
district attorney where he will
surrender before being arraigned in the
uh Criminal Court what are we going to
see tomorrow are we going to see
handcuffs are we going to see mug shots
what are we going to see tomorrow
yeah that's the the big question isn't
it still being negotiated we won't see
handcuffs that his lawyers have managed
to negotiate that one away at the moment
is looking like fingerprints most
certainly and probably a mug shot indeed
the chat is from inside team Trump but
there is that they wouldn't mind the mug
shot they can stick it on Trump T-shirts
because he is fundraising in Grand style
since his arrest five million dollars
and Counting with t-shirts like I stand
with Trump Euros for 36 dollars it
clearly has stirred the base use of his
arrest which as you say is heading this
way this is the international media on
Fifth Avenue street level far beneath
his apartment in Trump Tower where he
will spend the night the Trump apartment
at the top of that glass fronted
building floors 66 to 68 he's got the
top three floors modeled on the Palace
of Versailles were told 24 karat gold
mirror and marble during his Apprentice
TV series he was held to say some people
say it's the greatest apartment in the
world I couldn't possibly comment but
it's a nice apartment
I tell you what it is it's a lot more
salubrious than the kind of
accommodation he is going to endure
tomorrow at the Manhattan District
Courthouse in the Bowery area New York's
original Skid Row a former president
could scarcely fall any further rubbing
shoulders although one imagines there'll
be some distance between him and the
other common criminals at that
particular court building tomorrow who
come and go on a daily basis who are
fingerprinted they get a mock shot taken
they are put into handcuffs so you know
that's the role that Donald Trump will
fulfill tomorrow the fine detail of how
it will be handled and the kind of
issues around the Quorum are still being
negotiated there are Trump supporters on
that side of the road and on this side
of the wrote the go-to guy for comment
on behalf of trump is David REM David
you're from Queens yes sir Queens I'm
doing fine how about yourself I'm all
right listen let me ask you this I know
you support Trump I know you think this
is a political Witch Hunt so let me ask
you this nobody knows what the charges
are nobody knows what the case is why
not wait until we find out before you
decide whether it's a Witch Hunt or not
well we have an idea what the charges
are it involves Stormy Daniels and my
whole thing is why wasn't Bill Clinton
indicted and arrested for uh Paula Jones
I mean yeah never never mind anybody
else what about Donald Trump and the
specific charges anything of the charges
Donald Trump will prevail his lawyers
will prevail how do you know he's
innocent because I know he's innocent
and they prosecutors have refused to
turn over hundreds of pages of
information that will set him free okay
misconduct I'll tell you my final
question there was supposed to be a
homecoming celebration a gathering for
Donald Trump there are there's something
this is 11 o'clock in New York City
people work
people work okay David thank you very
much let's just have a very quick walk
down the street and give you a sense of
the scene you know many media hundreds
of media fake news on Fifth Avenue
tourists certainly rubbernecking and
many many New Yorkers strident New
Yorkers trying to go about their
business there is a huge Security
operation in place you can possibly see
some of the the officers around Trump
Tower 35
000 police officers from the NYPD have
been told to stand ready to turn up to
work in uniform in case they need to go
in police crowds at a moment's notice
and I'll show you something else maybe
just to the left you can see the a line
opposite Trump Tower you can see a line
of NYPD police coaches four or five of
them that is a a security shield in
front of the building part of a major
Security operation which of course will
ramp up when Donald Trump arrives in
Manhattan at LaGuardia Airport what did
you say Mark you'll then be escorted by
wrote by the NYPD
[Music]
clearly they are conscious of of danger
of danger to a former president
intelligence NYPD intelligence have been
on it for for several weeks now that's
why we see this kind of Security
operation in place we expect his arrival
here around mid-afternoon and of course
that onward Journey downtown and down
Market to Manhattan District Courthouse
at some stage tomorrow morning
[Music]
okay James thank you very much indeed uh
for the moment let's bring in Nile
stanage the associate editor of the US
political website the hill who I think
is in Washington uh for us now good to
talk to you just put this in perspective
for us what we're about to witness
tomorrow because this is not just a a
former president but it's also a
prospective president because he's
standing again
that's right Mark this is literally an
unprecedented situation I mean the first
time that any former president has been
indicted but as you say also a candidate
for the presidency next time around that
causes all kinds of complications one
example that I'll mention quickly is
that there has been some suggestion of
the judge here perhaps trying to impose
some kind of gag order on former
president Trump that seems
extraordinarily complicated if he is as
he is a candidate for the presidency in
2024 so it is a bizarre and dramatic
situation and obviously one that is
complicated because this case itself as
you have already mentioned is not really
as important as significant to American
democracy quite frankly as some of those
other legal challenges that former
president Trump is facing which which is
considered the most serious
investigation that he's facing and by
most serious I mean the one that could
threaten him politically most
to my mind the most dangerous for him is
the one in Georgia about interference in
the results of the 2020 election and it
hasn't honestly got as much publicity as
it might deserve but the reason I say
that Mark is in that case there is a
tape recording of Mr Trump then the
sitting president of the United States
speaking to the Secretary of State in
Georgia a threatening him essentially
and telling him to find not with his
words the precise number of votes
required to overcome President Biden's
victory in that state the evidence in
that Georgia case seems so clear-cut and
the underlying Behavior seems so serious
that I think that really does pose a
very significant threat to Mr Trump
yes because this was an attempt as you
suggest or an alleged attempt to
undermine that election the result of
which
he's never still hasn't accepted
that's exactly correct he continues to
utter falsehoods about that election and
say that it was fixed or rigged and it
is worth saying that his claims still
have considerable traction with
Republican voters if you look at a
population of uh Paul of the overall
population there are about one-third of
Americans do not believe that President
Biden's victory in 2020 was legitimate
that uh fire is one that has been both
ignited and stoked by Mr Trump with his
false claims and I think it continues to
be something that obviously causes real
uh problems and real worries as we look
at the the Civic Fabric in this country
yeah and it's extraordinary State of
Affairs is there a sense
in which this will play well for Donald
Trump politically that that you know he
we know he covets attention we know he
um covets controversy and we know he
likes to play the victim well this you
know gives him all of those things and
more
and 100 when it comes particularly to
the Republican primary we've already
seen Mark a couple of polls since the
news of the indictment broke suggesting
that Mr Trump has expanded his lead over
Florida Governor Ron DeSantis who I
heard you mentioned earlier so what
we're seeing is a rallying a round of
Republican voters to Mr Trump feeling
that he is the victim in all of this and
just to briefly add this case is one
that a lot of Democrats have uh
misgivings about this one going first
not only because the underlying events
seem kind of lured But ultimately less
important also because the kind of legal
theories behind this case are untested
at best and flimsy at worst they're
about whether this money is ultimately a
Undeclared campaign Finance declaration
or or a contribution and um we'll see
how it goes we'll see what evidence
Alvin Bragg the district attorney
actually has when it is unsealed
tomorrow but even for Democrats this
seems not a watertight case to put it
mildly
which begs the question why this is
happening because it is a effectively a
Democrat district attorney who's taken
this decision
it is that's right and I think that's an
important point to emphasize
particularly for a primarily British
audience we have this peculiarity really
in this country where these are elected
positions I mean Alvin Bragg you know
was a candidate for election to become
district attorney while he was a
candidate he emphasized his toughness he
certainly emphasized by pretty thinly
veiled implication that he would want to
go after uh former president Trump and
so that in turn then clearly makes it
easier for not just the former president
but for Republicans generally to portray
this as a politicized effort as a
politicized use of the justice system no
of course critics will say that's pretty
rich given some of the behavior of Mr
Trump while he was present and his
statements about how he would want the
justice department deployed but my point
is there are genuine uh reasons to worry
about political motivations in this case
yeah and I just wonder
if that is the case and
there is political motivation here
could that lead to
more indictments of future presidents
could it become a sort of political
weapon if you like
that is I think a real danger I mean the
the seal has been broken here so to
speak by this indictment remember you
know Richard Nixon was never indicted
for his role in Watergate for instance
uh you know there was a pardon issue
there and so forth it once you get into
this scenario where it is at least
plausible to indict a former president
then of course there is a danger of the
same premise being used for people in
the future now of course you have to
balance that with the idea that everyone
is equal before the law people are not
supposed to be above the law but but
look I mean you you know you look at how
he polarized the United States is right
now it seems entirely conceivable that a
future Republican Administration would
take aim at a democratic predecessor and
you could be very quickly into very
fraction anxious and Dangerous Waters
okay now thanks very much indeed let's
speak now as we wait uh to Palm Beach
airport we're just waiting for Donald
Trump to get on his plane and depart for
uh New York Mark Lottery's Chief
Communications officer at America First
policy Institute former director of
strategic Communications for
Donald Trump thank you for being with us
well he's the first
uh American president or former
president to be charged or he will be
charged with a crime
um it's all pretty humiliating isn't it
this is exactly what the uh the the
Liberals of the Democrats and their
mainstream Media Partners wanted they
don't really care about the outcome of
this case if they actually were to get a
conviction that's just icing on the cake
for them they want to be first they want
to be the first to indict Donald Trump
they want him to be the first president
to be impeached twice even though he was
acquitted in both counts I mean that's
really what this is about this is about
assassinating a man taking their taking
their political beef with a man using
the justice department and or using a
justice system to Target this one
individual when we've seen many many
other cases that do not get prosecuted
they just pay civil fines for uh for
campaign Finance violations
yeah well we don't know the detail of
the charges we don't know what's going
to happen what makes you so convinced
that it's a political Witch Hunt I mean
it was a grand jury people on a grand
jury that basically decided in the end
well there's an old saying in the
American legal system that a prosecutor
could indict a ham sandwich and that's
true you just have to get a majority of
the people to vote to convict and my
goodness in the state of New York in New
York City itself you put the Trump logo
on an apple and they will indict it uh
you know there's probably what 90
percent of people in that City hate
Donald Trump uh and it won't be hard to
find a majority that would indict him on
anything
Mark what do you think will happen
tomorrow do you think
you know he'll be handcuffed do you
think they'll mug shots will be
publicized will there be cameras in
court how do you think it's going to
play out tomorrow well I think from
everything I've read about the judge in
this case he'll play it by the book uh
that he is a stickler for for the
details in terms of how things have
traditionally done so whatever the rules
are in terms of New York in terms of
cameras in their courtrooms or anything
like that he'll follow those rules as
opposed to as it relates to his
indictment or his arraignment or his
booking it's my understanding that he
will be fingerprinted uh he will not be
handcuffed because he's already in the
custody for a lack of a better term uh
or already in the secret service federal
agent protection bubble so there's no
question about him being handcuffed and
uh and mug shots I've heard that you
know there may be a mug shot there may
not be it's against the law to leak a
mug shot but I'm sure that you know
obviously in New York that's what they
want so they will leak it out and I'm
sure the president and his legal team
will uh use it to uh to they're
benefited as well well that's an
interesting point do you think he'll
mind if his mug shot is circulated I
mean he loves the attention he loves
controversy and the thing about this
this you know it does cast him
as the victim and he we know how he he
likes that I mean do you think it will
play well for him politically
well I think definitely in a Republican
primary I mean as you as you mentioned
with your previous guest we have seen uh
the poll starting to separate and I
think the one thing that unites uh
Republicans conservatives people who
believe in America First realize that
there's a two-tier justice system in
America they see the Department of
Justice going after parents in our
country who simply just want to know
what's being taught to their kids in
schools so they'll be targeted but then
you see you don't see the same thing
going on the other side when you look at
whether it was the the summer of riots
and protests back in 2020 those charges
were dismissed look at the city of New
York most of the cases there are reduced
to misdemeanors meanwhile what could be
construed as a misdemeanor in this case
is being raised to a felony so they see
that there's two systems of Justice
going on right now it just depends on
who you support what event you attended
what tweet you liked or or what
candidate you may support for office
yeah we're just watching uh Donald
Trump's plane
sat on the tarmac still at Palm Beach
Airport in Florida he's heading to New
York to Laguardia Airport and then on to
Trump Tower where he'll spend the night
before being arraigned tomorrow I'm
speaking to Mark lotta former director
of strategic Communications for Donald
Trump and we were just talking Mark
about
how it could play well for Donald Trump
politically his core supporters I
imagine would
will rally to his side what about
moderate Republicans are they not
getting a bit fed up with the Trump
circus
well I think a certain extent what that
what they are seeing is that this is a
targeted political prosecution and so
people even people many people who might
have been look I liked him I voted for
him the first time around but I'm kind
of tired of that see this kind of action
and it brings them back into the fold I
I think that's one of the reasons why
you're seeing his poll numbers increase
in the primary because people are seeing
that here they go once again I mean we
actually talked about this in the 2020
campaign in the 2016 campaign and when I
was in the white house I mean there was
not a day that went by that the woke
left didn't wake up and hope that
today's the day we finally get him every
day they looked for a new reason to go
after him and get him and I think even
if people are tired of of some of the
other Antics they they see this
continued attack against this man and I
think it will bring many people back
into the fold uh whether uh when it
relates to a potential primary
right so you you you think he'll win the
primary do you
well there's a long time left we've
still got eight months until the first
voting is is uh is conducted in Iowa and
New Hampshire and anything and
everything can happen in those in these
next eight months uh right now he is the
odds on favorite the polls are are
indicative of that but that's what the
primary is about so if there is another
candidate or multiple candidates who can
make their connection with the voters
talk about the issues that matter to
them we'll see how the polls play out I
I remember back in you know in 2007 to
that late 2006 and 2007 even 2008 it was
Hillary Clinton's uh primary to lose she
was the senator from New York the the
former first lady and then this upstart
first term Senator from Illinois uh
caught fire really resonated with the
Democrat base and next thing you know
Barack Obama was nominated and obviously
went on to to win the White House so you
just don't know how these things are
going to play out this far in advance
well his catchphrase with Hillary
Clinton was a locker up one wonders what
the Democrats are
catchphrase will be
yeah you never know I mean obviously
they're gonna have to look for something
because you know this is the one
difference between in 2024 and I think
it should be noted doesn't matter who is
running on the Republican side in 2020
Joe Biden was a hypothetical president
he had not served as president you
really couldn't attack him for things
that Barack Obama did when he was vice
president and of course it'd been you
know a decade before when he was a
United States Senator so he was a
hypothetical president he's not a
hypothetical president in 2024. he has a
record and it's a bad record so whoever
comes out on the Republican side is
going to focus on out of control gas
prices Sky High inflation parents being
locked out of their of their kids school
board meetings and told that they're
terrorists if they ask questions these
things are actually going to be on the
ballot in 2024 and that's not something
that I'm thinking Joe Biden is ready to
defend
and just as we watch the plane uh move
on to the uh taxiway these other serious
investigations or more serious we should
say hovering over him the White House
documents removed to his Florida home
the January 6 attack on Congress
this pressurizing of the authorities in
Georgia which do you think has the
potential to
to cause him most problems
I think it'll just add it'll just keep
adding up and it's going to keep and
it's going to keep rallying his base
around him uh I don't think that any of
there's any one of these things is any
more serious I mean you want to talk
about classified documents Mike Pence
had them Joe Biden had them Joe Biden
had them for decades and they were
hiding in his garage next to his son's
car you know so I mean give me a break
uh these these kinds of disputes happen
and even when there have been prior to
speech like that they have been resolved
civilly they have been resolved uh you
know through negotiation not FBI raids
on uh on his home or trying to get him
uh obviously charged with a federal
crime so all of this plays into that
narrative that the the Democrats the
left the mainstream media are
weaponizing government against people
they disagree with politically and so it
doesn't matter what charges he faces
it's just going to be further proof to
so many people that there's two tears of
Justice one from the left and one for
the right
okay Mark uh thank you very much indeed
Mark Lotter appreciate your time uh
thank you today let's just go back to
Florida where that plane is about to
take off speak to uh Martha Kellner our
correspondent in Palm Beach and Martha
you've been talking no doubt to
Republicans in Florida what do they make
of what's Happening
I think I've mainly been talking to the
most entrenched Donald Trump supporters
these uh people who have supported him
throughout his unlikely political career
and certainly they seem galvanized by
this indictment they believe everything
that Donald Trump is telling them that
this is a politically motivated Witch
Hunt that these uh charges are being
instigated by democrats in order to wipe
Donald Trump off the political map and
many say it's made them even more
convinced that they're going to vote for
Donald Trump first uh they're going to
vote for him in the 2024 election and
interestingly it seems like this has
been a good fundraising motivation if
nothing else in the five days since this
indictment became public knowledge
they've been a flurry of emails from
Team Trump
urging supporters to donate to his 2024
campaign and many of them have obliged
he's made more than five million dollars
in campaign donation and just since last
Thursday so I think his hope is that he
can use these bad headlines to his
Advantage Trump of course a lifelong
subscriber to that school of thought
that all publicity is good publicity
although as he sits on that plane
waiting to take off from Palm Beach
airport surrounded by his closest aides
his secret service detail he must be
wondering whether in fact all publicity
is good publicity because he faces as
you were mentioning earlier that
humiliation of being treated like the
common criminal in New York tomorrow in
that court in the barry District of
Manhattan we expect him to be
fingerprinted to have his mugshot taken
that image could very well come to
Define his post-presidency so you have
to wonder how much that that theory of
all news being good news is being tested
with this indictment and of course it's
no small matter while some might see it
as a slightly trivial and certainly his
supporters here see it as trivial these
charges which we don't quite know the
exact detail of they could carry a
maximum sentence of four years in prison
Donald Trump already a relatively
elderly man that must be weighing heavy
on his mind and as he sits there waiting
to take off for New York City
yep and we were talking about uh this a
little earlier when we got interrupted
about Rhonda santis is who could well
turn out to be Trump's main Republican
rival and he is supporting uh Donald
Trump in this instance saying it is
Un-American and that that his state
state of Florida wouldn't wouldn't uh
support this uh it's interesting isn't
it
yeah what Ron DeSantis was saying before
Donald Trump offered to surrender
himself to face these charges he was
saying that as governor of Florida he
would not support an extradition of
Donald Trump to face these charges and
it is interesting because Donald Trump
in many ways sees himself as being the
king maker of the Republican Party he
sees himself as having propelled uh
Ronda santis to Greater political planes
but it is true as well that Ron DeSantis
is probably going to be the closest
rival to Donald Trump in any Republican
primary although DeSantis hasn't yet
declared that he will run most people
expect him to do so and Florida itself
is is an interesting state it used to be
a swing state that's now become a
stronghold for Republicans it's hugely
influential as a state in presidential
politics and many republican
um Republican strategists and think
tanks a deep camping from Washington DC
to Florida because they know that this
may become the center of America's
political Universe over the next couple
of years but yeah Ron versus Don
definitely a battle to watch
um Rhonda santis seen as being the young
Pretender to Donald Trump and but
certainly this indictment and those
potential looming other investigations
and charges could change the complexion
of that battle for the Republican
Candace candidacy for 2024
yes so uh Donald Trump is on his plane
and uh heading to New York the first
American President of former American
president to face criminal charges and
we know Martha that he's going to plead
not guilty
um and the truth is I suppose that the
case does rather revolve around and to
some extent
rely on his uh the evidence of his
discredited and former lawyer Michael
Cohen
yeah Michael Cohen um disbarred
disgraced former lawyer who I think sat
for at least a dozen interviews with
Federal prosecutors as they were
building up this case against Donald
Trump and we won't know exactly what
charges he faces until tomorrow
afternoon when the judge reads them out
in court many media organizations here
in the U.S were lobbying that judge to
try and get access to that indictment
that list of of charges
um before they're read out in court
tomorrow afternoon but it doesn't seem
at this point that that is likely to
happen so it will be tomorrow afternoon
when we publicly learn what charges
Donald Trump faces we do know though
that it is relating to hush money
payments made to the porn star Stormy
Daniels in the dying days of the 2016
election Trump had an extra marital
affair with Stormy Daniels those hush
money payments amounting to around 130
000 were made by the man that you
mentioned and Michael Cohen who has
already served a time in prison for
various crimes
um but that those those hush money
payments apologies that were made to
Stormy Daniels in and of themselves are
not illegal it's how these payments were
made and how they were declared and
specifically
um whether those payments were intended
to protect Donald Trump's marriage or to
protect his political career that is the
key Point here it's whether he broke
campaign financing rules but we won't
know as I mentioned again the exact
specifics of those charges until they're
read out by the judge in court tomorrow
afternoon
yeah and the
um
I mean we don't know when the trial will
take place if there will be a trial
because
we we understand or I certainly read
that his lawyers may even say that it's
not worth going to trial not worth
taking it to trial they might try that
one I mean when when could there be a
trial
what Donald Trump's team
always been
being delayed delay delay and this is a
much more difficult case to prove at
trial than it is simply to get this
indictment to get these charges across
the line in order and to get the charges
across the line at the Grand Jury only
had to indict him with a majority when
this goes to a jury trial if it does
reach a jury trial they would have to
unanimously convict so that is clearly a
much higher bar but because Donald
Trump's team using this delay delay
delay tactic it is a genuine possibility
that we could see
um a criminal trial into Donald Trump's
conduct in this matter running
concurrently to a presidential
um campaign so it's a very interesting
times coming up and just in case anyone
was wondering there is precedent in one
case of someone having run a
presidential campaign from prison so
that can happen of course rules were a
very long way away from that at the
moment this is just the initial stage
and where the charges will be read out
and Donald Trump will be given the
opportunity to plead guilty or not
guilty and of course we understand that
he will plead not guilty to these
charges
and uh even Donald Trump has to queue
uh the there's a queue of
flights taking off from Palm Beach
airport and uh Donald Trump is in the
darker of those so uh he'll be heading
to New York uh pretty soon Martha
Kellner is uh our correspondent in
Florida Martha what will be
um I mean the trial is one thing if and
when it happens what will be the process
in the next 24 hours that he'll go
through
well you can see obviously he's still in
that queue as you mentioned of planes
waiting to take off from Palm Beach
International Airport it's around
um a two-hour 10-minute flight to
LaGuardia Airport which is in the Queens
district of New York and motorcade will
be waiting to pick him up at the other
side clearly uh the police on hyla in
Manhattan for the potential disturbances
he'll be driven from Queens to the
Manhattan District of New York he'll
stay overnight at Trump Tower which is
his residence there we're not quite sure
what he will do tomorrow morning there
is a window of time at the moment that
is there to play for so we don't know
where the hill come out in public we do
know that that hearing itself will take
place around 2 15 p.m in the afternoon
at that court in the barry District of
Manhattan and at the moment it's not
quite clear how they will get Donald
Trump
um into that court whether he will be
handcuffed there have been instances
um before of sort of a high profile uh
people having handcuffs placed in front
of them rather be than behind them
um like the common criminal if you like
there's also talk that potentially there
could be a tented route into that
courthouse so we may not get a glimpse
of Donald Trump as he makes his way into
that Courthouse there will then be this
hearing and after that he will leave the
courtroom there's because this is white
collar crime there's no possibility he
will be
um held in prison he will be released he
will then be free
um to make his way back onto Trump Force
One and he will fly back to Palm Beach
International Airport at which point his
motorcade will bring him back to where I
am at the moment
um to his Mar-A-Lago estate we then know
he will take opportunity
um or make the most of the spotlight
being on him by making a prime time
address tomorrow evening from inside
Mar-A-Lago he will make address around 8
15 p.m and that's the first time that we
will see him on camera reacting to these
Federal criminal charges and so that
will clearly be an incredibly
interesting moment as he makes that
appearance back at Mar-A-Lago around 8pm
tomorrow evening and so a good time to
make the headlines with the evening
broadcasts here in America
right we were just talking to Donald
Trump's former director of
Communications on the program and he was
talking about he
how he felt that it would all play well
for Trump politically he thinks he'll
get off the charge and that you know it
will just
be once again Donald Trump portrayed as
the the victim just give us the truth
about what has happened since the
indictment was announced because he's
claiming his poll numbers are up
um against the other possible
uh American
presidential candidates Republican
presidential candidate he also says that
his funding is up there was four million
dollars
he reckons Donald Trump reckons in the
24 hours after it was announced is that
what is happening
I I think the polls are still favorable
for Donald Trump certainly it doesn't
seem to have impacted uh his standing as
a potential
um well as a presidential candidate has
of course confirmed that he's running in
2024 and if we're to take the amount of
money he's raised since this indictment
has become public has become public
knowledge then it certainly seems to be
working in his favor he says four
million dollars in the first 24 hours
since this became public knowledge on
Thursday I understand it's now at least
um five million dollars that he's made
in campaign donations and there's
certainly been a flurry of emails from
his team into the inboxes of trump
supporters asking for support against
um against this indictment I mentioned
before he had his first um 2024 campaign
rally interestingly in Waco Texas I I
think he's just about to take off on
that plane now I think the the wheel
just just leaving the tarmac now Trump
on his way to New York a different angle
there and for that just just around
um two-hour journey to New York a
historic Journey the first president
ever to face criminal charges
um Donald Trump there on his way to New
York on his way and to find out or on
his way and for the public unveiling of
these criminal charges against him a
very interesting moment for Donald Trump
and an interesting moment for this
country as it Witnesses a moment in
history really
yep it is uh six o'clock and uh in
London it is one o'clock as you can see
in the Palm Beach and Donald Trump has
left uh Palm Beach airport and is now on
his way the first American president or
former president to face criminal
charges he will be arraigned tomorrow he
is uh in the air that is not him he is
in the air he is that's his plane he is
in the spotlight which he likes and uh
in three hours time or two and a half
hours time or so he will be in New York
and Martha Kellner is still on the
ground in Florida and just a final
thought Martha I mean there's a big
moment in uh modern American history
certainly is the first ever
author president to face criminal
charges and I think sometimes with the
trauma of Donald Trump's career the
significance of this moment is almost
lost because we do have these flurry of
Investigations ongoing but I think
important as well and you've reflected
on it a few times Mark is that this is
not even the most serious of those
potential criminal charges that Donald
Trump faces and many people think the
fact that they've reached the stage of
formal criminal charges against Donald
Trump in this case in the Stormy Daniels
case means that it could open the door
of the criminal charges in other cases
in the case which is looking in to his
role in the storming of the capital on
January the 6th his role potentially in
campaign interference in the counting of
votes in the state of Georgia for the
2020 election many people believe this
could just be the start of Donald
Trump's criminal Reckoning but as we've
seen with the choreographed drama here
his team keeping media informed of his
every movement movement as he makes his
way to New York Donald Trump determined
to remain the center of attention he's
shown throughout his career that he's
capable of turning any event into a soap
opera style spectacle and clearly these
pending Federal criminal charges really
serious criminal charges and no
exception to that rule
yeah and just to be clear whatever
happens tomorrow I mean he walks away
from that court and the process begins
and it could well be a very long process
yeah it certainly could these are our
white collar crimes as we've mentioned
again and again we don't know
specifically what crimes he's accused of
but they are non-violent crimes so there
would be no occasion where the judge
would rule that he has to remain in
prison until this trial happens if it
does eventually reach trial so he will
be released tomorrow afternoon tomorrow
at perhaps tomorrow early tomorrow
evening after the conclusion of that
hearing he will then travel back to
legality airport back onto Trump force
one of his private plane and back here
to Mar-A-Lago where he will make a
public Prime Time address where he will
once again presumably try to train this
indictment these criminal charges as a
politically motivated Witch Hunt he will
try once again to spin these bad
headlines into positive momentum for his
campaign for the presidency in 2024.
Martha thanks very much quick uh final
word on this from James Matthews who is
at Trump Tower in New York and James
just give us Donald Trump on his way to
where you are just give us a sense of
the mood there there were talks of a
talk of protests what's happening
from
nothing like the kind of crowds that
we've seen around this sort of occasion
in the past this is a man remember who
on his social media account uh posted
protest take our nation back I have to
say in the the week and a half to a
fortnight since that we haven't seen any
kind of numbers backing him I suppose
the scene may change in due course we're
still 36 hours from that court
appearance I can tell you mark there are
some details around the choreography of
that appearance in downtown Manhattan
Donald Trump will go there or be driven
there in the company of course of the
Secret Service who are charged with his
security
no DNA will be taken from him he will be
fingerprinted in terms of a mug shot I'm
told that is yet to be decided there are
ongoing negotiations with his lawyers
around the decorum of the court
appearance of a former president but for
now I suppose it's all about security
here on Fifth Avenue he will arrive at
Trump Tower after that flight after a
drive escorted by the NYPD Uptown here
to to Trump Tower where he occupies the
top three floors he'll spend the night
inside that apartment overlooking
Central Park and well there will be some
contrast between that and the the
austere surroundings ahead of him in a
courtroom in New York's Brewery a very
austere building that accommodates
criminals on a daily basis counts them
in counts them out in handcuffs usually
they come before a judge for Donald
Trump it will be the 15th floor before
judge mash and a man who he has already
criticized he hates me said Donald Trump
on his social media account he's also
criticized the prosecutor so look for
that to be a continuing theme for Donald
Trump when he has something to say and
as Martha said we expect that public
statement to come in Mar-A-Lago when
he's made the return trip tomorrow
evening
okay James thank you very much indeed
and he's already got something to say he
has just uh put out a message on his
truth social platform and it says very
simply Witch Hunt as our once great
country is going to hell that's the view
of Donald Trump as he heads to uh New
York City uh this evening